tổng ra soát lắm sạch trưởng ngoán, kết lối với khai thách trên và bị toàn hệ thống chiến chỉ.
Các buộc gành với ngoàn thay in cái việc tạo lập trưởng ngoán các pic.
Cơ sở giữ liệu trình gành, khẩn trưởng kết lối, chia sẻ viết,
rửa liệu với trường tâm giữ liệu của gây hảy thách dùng trung theo cuối đệ,
chấm giữ kết những trạm giữ liệu phân tán các cứu không tương tích.
Sắc lập băng được, chỉ có trung trung, về rửa liệu hảy thống thông tình trong mệt thống chiến chỉ.
Yêu tiền phát triển, tình số dùng trung, nền tàn thống dùng dùng giữ liệu hảy thống chiến chỉ.
Lấy máy, các cái nhiều vụ chuyển tổ số phụ vụ vận hảy nè,
thống chiến chỉ của chiến quyền bác cấp, đồng vộ thông xuất với hệ quảy.
Tập trung hoàn tiền hảy thần số đồng vộ thì trung hoàn lên cấp sát,
đồng mạo các cái điều kiện để chiến quyền cấp vận hảy,
cho một chuyển số tật xích phật lợi.
Lấy máy tạc tụ tụ quảy chính, cảm thấy chuyển tổ số,
tập trung hoàn tiền, cảm thấy tụ quốc gia và thông xuất hiệu quảy.
Một điều quy công, có một chuyện tiền, phải tất chất tụi tiền để giữ sử dụng chú dạm được,
thời gian và chỉ phía trong những dân trời nhớ.